Prof: Good morning
everyone.
Back to Rome today,
back to Rome,
which was beginning to emerge
as the world's,
or the ancient world's,
greatest superpower,
an emergence that we're going
to see had a profound impact on
Roman architecture.
And we'll also see that there
were a number of men who
effected this superstardom for
Rome,
and they're men that I'm going
to talk about with you today.
These included Julius Caesar,
Pompey the Great,
Mark Antony,
and Octavian Augustus,
especially Octavian Augustus:
Augustus,
first emperor of Rome,
and it's the reason that I have
decided to call this lecture
today "From Brick to
Marble: Augustus Assembles
Rome."
You see on the left-hand side
of the screen a portrait of
Julius Caesar.
It's a green diabase portrait
of Caesar.
It's now in Berlin,
and I believe actually that it
is a portrait that was
commissioned by Cleopatra
herself.
She commissioned it for a
building that she and Caesar
were putting up in Alexandria,
called the Caesareum that
honored Caesar,
and you can see that he is
represented as he was--
it's a quite realistic portrait
with the lines and wrinkles,
with his receding hairline and
so on accentuated in this
portrait.
On the right hand-side of the
screen we see an image of Pompey
the Great, a marble portrait
that is now in the Ny Carlsberg
Glyptotek, in Copenhagen.
And a portrait that shows that
Pompey the Great very much
wanted to ally himself with
Alexander the Great,
because if you look at his very
full head of hair,
you can see that he wears it in
the center,
pushed up in a kind of
pompadour, which is a reference
to the same kind of upsweep that
was worn by Alexander the Great.
I want to give you a little bit
of information about Caesar,
about his life,
about some of his
accomplishments,
because these are going to have
an impact on the architecture,
on our discussion of the
architecture that he
commissioned in Rome.
We know that Caesar was elected
consul, in 59 B.C.
He then joined with Pompey the
Great, and with a man by the
name of Crassus,
to form what is known as the
First Triumvirate.
The result of that First
Triumvirate was in part that
Caesar received a consulship in
Gaul.
But despite all good
intentions, just a few years
later, in 54 B.C.,
the Triumvirate fell apart.
Difficult times were the case
in Rome between 53 and 50 B.C.
There were food shortages and
riots in the city,
and the Senate was very
concerned that these uprisings
would lead to a takeover by the
populace of the city.
Pompey took charge.
He took control of the Senate
and he restored order,
and his reward for so doing is
that the Senate was willing to
work with him to try to
overthrow his rival,
that is, Julius Caesar.
Crassus, the other member of
the Triumvirate,
had since died.
But Caesar got the upper hand,
at the end of the day,
and it was Caesar who defeated
Pompey the Great at a very
famous battle,
the Battle of Pharsalos,
which took place in 48 B.C.
After the Battle of Pharsalos
and his defeat by Julius Caesar,
Pompey fled to Egypt where he
was murdered,
and in fact the Egyptians slit
Pompey's head,
put it on a plate and presented
it to Caesar.
Now you'd think Caesar would
have been happy about that.
He wasn't, because although he
was thrilled to have defeated
Pompey the Great,
he did not like seeing the head
of a fellow Roman delivered to
him on a plate.
Caesar, at that point,
despite his victory,
what was foremost in his mind
was his affair with Cleopatra,
and he stayed in Egypt with
Cleopatra for a period of time.
But in 45 B.C.,
by 45 B.C., he had returned to
Rome.
He was acclaimed Dictator in
that year,
in 45, and after that he
pursued fiscal reforms for Rome,
and also he commissioned a
number of very important public
works,
and that's where Roman
architecture obviously comes
into play.
Despite the fact that he
initiated those reforms and
built buildings and built up the
city in interesting ways,
the aristocrats in Rome
considered Caesar a tyrant.
They considered him a tyrant
because they felt that the
influence of Cleopatra had
rubbed off too much on him and
his ambitions were too
monarchical,
and the aristocrats encouraged
his murder.
And he was assassinated,
as all of you know,
by Cassius and Brutus in the
year 44 B.C.,
on the Ides of March,
and he was divinized by the
Senate,
he was made a god by the
Senate, in the year 42 B.C.
In his biography of Julius
Caesar,
the writer Suetonius,
who was a secretary and a
biographer to the emperor
Hadrian in the second century
A.D.,
Suetonius wrote a biography of
the Twelve Caesars,
a very famous biography that
many of you may know served as
the basis for Robert Graves'
very well-known Claudius,
which also accentuates again
the biographies of those first
Twelve Caesars.
And although Caesar himself was
dictator, not emperor,
he is the first of the Caesars
who is covered by Suetonius.
And in Suetonius' biography of
Julius Caesar,
he tells us about some of these
major architectural commissions
that Caesar embarked on in Rome.
And it's interesting to read
about these because we'll see
that all of them seem to have
been the best and the greatest.
And I think one of the
explanations for this is the
time that Caesar spent in
Alexandria, in Egypt,
with Cleopatra.
She wanted to show him the
sites, and in fact they went on
a very famous barge trip
together,
down the Nile,
in which she showed him the
pyramids and the sphinxes that
were there to be seen.
And he was extremely impressed
by what he saw in Egypt,
and decided that one of the
most important things that he
could do,
that he could contribute to
posterity vis-à-vis Rome,
was to make Rome into a city
that was the equal of
Alexandria,
that had similar large-scale
buildings and impressive
monuments,
the way Alexandria did.
So he came back to Rome,
he undertook this major
building project,
and Suetonius tells us that he
built--
he wanted to build,
he started to build a Temple to
Mars that Suetonius describes as
the biggest in the world.
Why?
To compete with the buildings
of Alexandria.
A vast--not just a theater--a
vast theater.
Greek and Latin public
libraries.
We know, of course,
that the greatest library in
the ancient world at this
particular time was the Library
at Alexandria.
So he wanted libraries in Rome
that could compete with the
great Library of Alexandria.
And he was also particularly
interested in engineering
marvels.
He built, or he began to build,
a highway from the Adriatic,
across the Apennines,
to the Tiber,
and then most famously a canal
cut through the Isthmus of
Corinth.
That was, in large part,
achieved, and one can still see
that canal, if one visits
Corinth in Greece today.
So he had vast ambitions.
But many of these ambitions
were cut short by his
assassination in 44 B.C.
He was not able to achieve
architecturally all that he had
hoped.
One building that he was able
to complete, or almost complete,
was a forum in Rome.
The Forum Iulium,
I-u-l-i-u-m,
which is after his family name
Iulius.
The Forum Iulium,
or as we usually call it the
Forum of Julius Caesar in Rome
was a building that he was able
to begin in the year 52 B.C.,
and then it was inaugurated in
46 B.C.,
which is a couple of years
before his assassination.
It wasn't quite finished at the
time of its inauguration and it
was left to Caesar's follower,
Augustus, first emperor of
Rome, to actually complete some
of the details of the forum.
But for all intents and
purposes it was done by 46.
I show you a Google Earth
aerial view of the Roman Forum,
as you see it here--we've
looked at this before--
the Roman Forum,
the Colosseum,
just for you to get your
bearings,
the Circus Maximus,
the Palatine Hill,
the Capitoline Hill,
the Victor Emmanuel Monument
here,
Mussolini's Via dei Fori
Imperiali here,
the so-called Imperial Fora,
of which Augustus' forum,
which we're also going to talk
about today is a part.
The Forum of Caesar is very
close to the Roman Forum.
It's located just to the left
here, and above,
the wedding cake of Victor
Emmanuel.
You see it here,
and you can barely make out the
three columns that are still
preserved from the temple that
was located inside this forum.
So you can see it was adjacent
to, and in fact connected to,
the Roman forum that lay over
here.
So a forum, and in that forum a
temple,
a temple to Venus,
Venus Genetrix,
G-e-n-e-t-r-i-x,
who was the divine ancestress
of the Julian family.
The Julian family traced its
ancestry back to Venus via
Aeneas, through Aeneas.
So this was the very special
patron goddess of not only
Caesar himself but of the Julian
family.
This is a plan of the Forum of
Julius Caesar,
as it would have looked when
the building was inaugurated in
46 B.C.
And I think you can see here
that it has two major
prototypes, models that were
being looked back at when this
was designed,
beginning in 52.
You can see that it is based
heavily on earlier Roman forum
-- Samnite/Roman forum design --
as we saw it in the city of
Pompeii;
think of the Forum of Pompeii.
But it also was based in part
on a building that we have not
looked at and which no longer
survives,
but we have information about,
and that is that Caesareum,
or Caesareum of Julius Caesar,
that he and Cleopatra put up in
Alexandria.
And we know enough about that
building to know it too was an
open rectangular space with
colonnades around it and a
temple as part of it.
So this whole idea of temple in
a rectangular complex.
We see it in Alexandria.
Contemporaneously we see it
earlier in Pompeii at the Forum
of Pompeii.
So a great open rectangular
space, open to the sky,
with colonnades on either side.
You can see on this side there
are some additional chambers,
and based on what those look
like in plan,
I am sure you can tell me what
they are.
Does anyone know?
Think back to what we saw in
Pompeii that looked similar to
this.
What are these here?
What?
Student:
>
Prof: Storage did you
say, or-- Student:
Storage.
Prof: Storage.
Not exactly storage;
shops, tabernae.
Remember the tabernae
that we saw fronting the houses
in Pompeii.
These are a series of shops,
or tabernae,
opening off the left colonnade
of the forum,
and then on one of the short
sides,
pushed up against the back
wall--in fact,
in this case,
almost projecting out of the
forum to a certain extent--
the Temple of Venus Genetrix.
We can see it in plan,
and it dominates the space in
front of it, just as the
Capitolium did at Pompeii.
We can see the general plan
conforms to early Roman temple
architecture,
as we've described it,
with its use of the Etruscan
plan and the Greek elevation.
We can see that there is--well
I'll show you this in a moment,
but take my word--it has a high
podium;
it has a deep porch;
it has freestanding columns in
that porch.
It has a façade
orientation,
although one idiosyncrasy of
this particular temple is that
the staircase is located,
not just on the front,
but on the two sides,
but only at the level of the
podium.
The staircase does not encircle
the building,
as it would have in a Greek
temple,
but it goes beyond the front to
the sides of the podium,
to allow access to it that way
as well.
A single entrance,
because this is the Temple of
Venus and not the Capitoline
Triad,
and then columns,
freestanding columns on either
side,
but a flat back wall very much
in the Etruscan manner.
So a temple that is very much
in keeping with the other kind
of temple architecture that we
have seen thus far.
What's significant though again
is that the choice of goddess to
honor here,
the fact that it is Venus
Genetrix,
a personal goddess,
from the point of view of
Julius Caesar:
someone who was associated
closely with his family,
with the genesis of his family,
and not with the Roman State as
a whole.
And that's a very important
distinction,
the difference between putting
up a temple to the Capitoline
Triad,
a very state-oriented thing to
do, and putting up a temple to
your own personal goddess.
It signals a certain change
vis-à-vis the way these
individuals thought about
themselves,
and may again have had
something to do with the way
Caesar was perceived in Rome,
and to his eventual demise.
In fact, I should also add that
Caesar,
because of his relationship
with Cleopatra,
ended up putting up a statue of
Cleopatra as the Egyptian
goddess Isis,
in this temple as well,
standing right next to Venus
Genetrix.
Which was a pretty arrogant and
probably a pretty stupid thing
to do in Republican Rome where
Cleopatra was considered a very
interesting public figure,
because she did come with him
to visit Rome at one point,
but was also maligned by many
among the aristocracy as an
enemy of Rome.
I'm showing you here a view of
the Forum of Caesar,
as it looks today,
and you can see the columns on
the left-hand side,
from the colonnade.
Some of those still stand.
You can see the staircase or
the foundations of the staircase
and the podium,
tall podium again,
of the Temple of Venus
Genetrix.
But you can see that only a
very small number,
three in fact,
of the columns are preserved.
So it is in actually quite
ruinous state.
And what you're looking at here
is actually not even,
for the most part,
the Julian building,
because we know that this
building was seriously damaged
in a fire,
later, and that it was restored
by the emperor Domitian,
in the late first century A.D.,
and then by the emperor Trajan,
into the early second century
A.D.
And so what stands today is
primarily a later structure.
But we do believe it was based
very closely on the original
Julian building,
and in that regard is a very
good reflection of what it would
have looked like.
This coin over here shows the
temple as it was in the time of
Julius Caesar.
We see the altar in the front,
the altar;
because the sacrifice always
takes place in the front of a
Roman temple.
The temple itself,
with its columns that are
parted on this coin,
only to show the statue of
Venus Genetrix inside:
the cult statue.
The colonnades on either side.
And then if you look closely at
the pediment,
you can see that there's
sculpture in there,
and we have literary
descriptions of what that
sculpture depicted,
and we know it was a scene of
Venus rising from the sea:
so Venus Genetrix rising from
the sea.
The closest thing probably to
it is something like,
for those of you who know
it--Botticelli's Primavera
in Florence is probably
sort of the idea here for
emerging from the waters,
and her depiction in this
particular pediment above.
And we know that there were
also scenes of cupids carrying
the arms and armor,
probably of Mars.
This is me with a former
graduate student of mine and
pointing out--
he wrote a dissertation on the
Forum of Caesar,
which was afterwards published
as a book.
But he's pointing out to me
here some of the architectural
detail that still survives,
that one can see when one
wanders through that forum
today.
And you can see the very deep
drill work here,
deep drill work that is
actually not characteristic of
the time of Julius Caesar,
but rather of the time of
Domitian and Trajan.
So probably this decoration
belongs to the later renovation
of this particular structure.
This gives you perhaps the best
idea of what the temple would
have looked like in the forum:
a restored view of the Temple
of Venus Genetrix in the Forum
of Julius Caesar,
with its inscription telling us
that Caesar,
a dictator of Rome, put it up;
"fecit,"
as you can see here.
You can see the tall podium.
You can see the façade
orientation, although again
there was a staircase on three
sides of that podium.
You can see the birth of Venus
in the pediment above.
You can see the columns over
here of the side,
the colonnade of one--of the
left side of the forum,
which would have had statues on
bases.
The shops behind.
And most importantly what this
restored view shows you is the
relationship between the Temple
of Venus Genetrix and Caesar's
Forum,
and the Capitolium,
on the top of the Capitoline
Hill.
Because when you take away the
Victor Emmanuel Monument,
which is there now and which we
saw in the earlier image,
you can see that the building
that was up on top of the hill
at this particular time was of
course the Capitolium,
the Temple of Jupiter OMC.
And I mentioned to you at the
time we talked about the Temple
of Jupiter OMC,
although the Campidoglio,
as redesigned by Michelangelo,
with the Senatorial Palace in
the back,
which is where the Temple of
Jupiter OMC was,
faces modern Rome.
The ancient temple faced
ancient Rome,
faced the Roman Forum,
and so you see it facing the
Roman Forum in this restored
view.
So I don't think it was
coincidental.
The Romans were very careful,
as we've learned,
about how they sited their
buildings, and they liked to
make references from one
building to another.
I don't think it is any
coincidence that Caesar chose
this site for his Temple of
Venus so that anyone who gazed
at it would also see,
out of the corner of their eye,
the Temple of the Capitoline
Triad,
on the Capitoline Hill,
and that would only enhance
Caesar's stature in the eyes of
his contemporaries.
You see now portraits of Mark
Antony,
on the right-hand of the
screen, a black basalt portrait
of Antony,
now in England,
and a portrait of Rome's first
emperor,
Octavian Augustus,
on the left-hand of the screen,
a fantastic bronze image of him
that was part of an equestrian
statue found in the North Sea
near Greece.
With regard to Antony and
Octavian, after Caesar's
assassination in 44 B.C.,
it was Mark Antony who rose to
power.
Octavian was only 19 at the
time--so your age--and he was
the grandnephew of Caesar.
So he had a familial
relationship,
although a fairly distant one,
to Caesar: the grandnephew of
Caesar.
And this 19-year-old upstart
tried to overthrow Mark Antony,
and he was not successful.
In the wise "If you can't
beat them,
join them"
way of thinking about life and
the world,
Octavian joined,
with Antony,
with Mark Antony,
and a man by the name of
Lepidus, to form what we know of
as the Second Triumvirate,
and that happened in the year
43 B.C.
Once they had formed the Second
Triumvirate together,
Octavian and Antony took all of
their military forces--
and each of them had a
considerable amount--
and they combined them,
with the objective of going
after Cassius and Brutus:
Cassius and Brutus who you'll
remember had murdered Caesar.
And they were successful at so
doing.
They beat and murdered Cassius
and Brutus at the Battle of
Philippi, in the year 42 B.C.
A very important battle,
the Battle of Philippi in 42
B.C.
Mark Antony,
who not only rose to power
after Caesar's assassination,
but rose in the life and times
of Cleopatra.
They had entered into--well
there's some rumors that this
happened, or began much earlier
in time.
But at any rate,
Mark Antony takes up with
Cleopatra and he joins her in
Egypt and he spends a good deal
of his time in the eastern part
of the Empire with his paramour.
Octavian very smartly realized
Antony is distracted.
"This is a perfect time
for me to try once again to gain
the supreme power that I want.
I don't want to be part of a
threesome, I want to rule Rome
completely, myself."
And he defeats Antony and
Cleopatra at one of the most
famous battles of all time,
the Battle of Actium,
a naval battle which took place
off the northwestern coast of
Greece,
in 31 B.C.
After that very famous battle,
Antony and Cleopatra commit
suicide and Octavian becomes the
sole emperor of this newly
emerging super power,
and he is appointed as
Augustus, which meant that he
had a special kind of majesty,
in the year 27 B.C.
We have additional information
about Augustus from Suetonius'
biography of him--
he wrote one of him obviously
as well--
and from Augustus' own account
of his life and of his
accomplishments.
I mentioned that Octavian--and
that's called the Res Gestae
Divi Augusti--
I mentioned that Octavian took
the title of Augustus in 27
B.C.,
and he was emperor of Rome for
a very long time,
from that year 27 until his
death in AD 1.4.,
at the age of 76,
which was a very ripe old age
to live to,
at a time when most
people--women were dying in
childbirth at 10 to 20,
and men were dying,
for the most part,
in their thirties.
So 76 was a very old age
indeed, in ancient times,
and it meant that Augustus was
emperor of Rome for a very long
period, as you can see.
Now at his death,
Augustus deposited three
documents,
besides his will,
with the Vestal Virgins in
Rome,
and these included instructions
for his funeral;
a kind of state of the union
address;
what was the situation in Rome
and in the Empire,
at the time of his death,
or right before his death?
And then most importantly for
us, a résumé
of his acts,
a résumé
of all of his accomplishments
during his lifetime,
which were meant to be carved
on two bronze plaques that were
to be set up in front of his
tomb in Rome.
These are the famous Res
Gestae Divi Augusti,
and that means the list of
things accomplished of the
divine Augustus,
because Augustus,
like Caesar before him,
was made a god,
was transformed into a god at
his death.
And this lists all of his
accomplishments at home and
abroad--
the battles that he won,
the cities that he formed--
but most important for us,
it lists dozens and dozens of
building projects.
For example,
it lists eighty-two temples
that he either restored or built
in Rome, in Rome itself.
So it gives you some sense of
the magnitude of this man's
building objectives and is very
important to us as a compendium
of what he does.
Some of these buildings still
survive.
Some of them don't.
But this is a very informative
list indeed,
and it shows us that to
Augustus, as to Caesar before
him,
the building of buildings was
extremely important:
the making of buildings not
only to remake Rome as a great
city of the ancient world,
but also to leave something for
posterity,
and, of course,
both of them were successful in
both of those objectives.
Very important for us today are
also the words of Suetonius.
Suetonius tells us that
Augustus bragged that he--
and I quote--"found Rome a
city of brick,
and left Rome a city of
marble."
A city of brick,
meaning that brick tile that we
saw in Pompeii,
he found a Rome that was built
out of that same kind of brick
tile that we saw at Pompeii,
but he wanted to transform,
he left the city of Rome a city
of marble.
And that's exactly the major
thrust of today's lecture:
Augustus builds Rome as a
marble city in the model of
ancient Greece,
in the model of Athens,
in the Greek part of the world.
It's a rhetorical exaggeration,
but we're going to see,
from the two Augustan buildings
that I show you today,
that it wasn't far off the
mark, that he really did create
a city of marble,
on the Tiber,
and he left for posterity that
Greek marble city,
a Hellenized city that builds
on the Hellenization of Roman
architecture that we've already
talked about.
What made Augustus' boast
possible was the fact for the
first time in its history a high
quality marble was available to
Rome, in close proximity;
that is, marble from Italy
itself, as opposed to imported
marbles.
We've seen up to this point
that the Romans wanted to build
marble buildings;
that they created faux marble
walls, the First Style,
at Pompeii for example,
and also in Rome.
That they created temples with
columns and superstructures that
were made out of tufa,
or travertine,
and then they stuccoed those
over white,
to make them look like marble,
even though they were not
marble.
But that they just didn't have
access to marble readily enough
to transform,
to actually make these
buildings out of marble itself.
There was some flirtation with
it.
They did import a certain
amount of Greek marble to use,
for some buildings,
but it wasn't available at a
low enough cost to allow the
kind of full-scale marble
building that they wanted to do.
What happens in the end of the
reign of Caesar and into--
or the dictatorship of Caesar
and into the emperorship of
Augustus is that all of a sudden
a high quality,
relatively inexpensive marble
becomes available.
Because what happens is the
Romans begin to exploit,
in the late Caesarian period
and into the age of Augustus,
the marble quarries at Luna,
on the northwest coast of
Italy.
This is the same town as modern
Carrara, the same quarries that
were used centuries later by
none other than Michelangelo
himself.
Carrara marble,
you all know Carrara marble,
called Luna,
the site called Luna in ancient
Roman times.
So Luna or Carrara marble.
I show you a view here of the
marble quarries,
or one of the marble quarries,
at Luna/Carrara,
what it looks like today.
This is a re-enactment of
bringing the marble blocks down
from the mountain for use in
construction.
They basically do it the same
way today as they probably did
it in ancient Roman times.
And it was fairly easy to get
this.
Since it was on the coast,
it was fairly easy to load this
marble into boats,
bring it down to Ostia,
and then up the Tiber to Rome.
And that began to be done,
with great success,
especially in the age of
Augustus.
Going to Carrara today is a
pleasure.
It's an interesting place to
visit,
especially if you go there at
the time of the marble
exhibition that they have and
the competition that they have
where people make whatever out
of Carrara marble and compete
for prizes.
And I show you a view taken
during one of these contests
here now on the screen.
And there are some amazing,
amazing works of art,
we might call them,
that come out of these
competitions.
Here's one of my favorites.
You see over here the Luna
marble version of an Italian
Cinquecento.
These Cinquecentos,
which were miniscule,
are not--not many of them exist
today, although you do see some
antique versions here and there.
But I had one of these once,
and you can see a picture of me
in fact here,
in front of American Express,
not far from the Spanish Steps,
the Piazza di Spagna,
with my Cinquecento.
It was a long time ago.
But you can see how small it is.
I'm actually standing on the
front passenger side and popping
up through the sun roof.
But my size there--and I'm
about 5'7--compared to the car,
gives you some sense of how
small these cars were today.
So the Italians have been very
good about this sort of thing
for some time,
and continue,
as you well know,
to drive,
for the most part,
small cars through the city.
And another one of my favorite
entries into the competition are
these Luna marble decapitated
heads of Juan and Evita
Perón that were put
forward in one of these
competitions some years ago.
With regard to transforming
Rome into a marble city,
now that Carrara marble was
available at a fairly low cost,
compared to the importation of
Greek marbles,
Augustus begins to build his
marble city.
And I'm going to show you two
major commissions of Augustus
today.
The first of these is the Forum
of Augustus in Rome,
a forum--or the Forum Augustum
in Rome--
that was very much in Augustus'
mind from the beginning of his
rise to power.
In fact, it's Suetonius who
tells us that the reason that
Augustus built a forum in Rome
was because even though there
were already two forums in
Rome--
that includes the Roman Forum
and the Forum of Julius Caesar--
even though those two existed
and were both being used,
that the population--Suetonius
tells us the population was
growing by leaps and bounds,
as were the need to try
judicial cases,
and that the spaces in the
forums--of the Roman Forum,
and in the Forum of Julius
Caesar--did not allow for the
needs of the populace or for the
needs of these judicial cases,
and that they needed to build
another forum.
Well, that's a good story,
but the likelihood is it had
pretty much nothing to do with
that--
it may have had something to do
with that,
but not a lot to do with
that--because Augustus had
ulterior motives.
Augustus -- it was at the
Battle of Philippi,
that battle of 42 B.C.
when Mark Antony and Octavian
joined forces to defeat the
assassins of Julius Caesar.
It was right before that battle
that Augustus vowed that if he
won,
if he were successful,
that he would build a temple to
Mars the Avenger,
Mars Ultor, U-l-t-o-r,
Mars Ultor, Mars the Avenger,
in gratitude for helping him
avenge the death of Julius
Caesar,
the murder of Julius Caesar,
the assassination of Julius
Caesar.
And so when he was successful,
he said, "I will build
that temple."
And that temple needed an
environment,
and as we've seen,
Romans often built temples
inside complexes,
whether it was sanctuaries or
forums,
and so he had a good excuse to
build a major forum in Rome,
as a domicile for the Temple of
Mars Ultor.
He didn't get around to it for
awhile--
again, the Battle of Philippi,
42--but he had a lot of other
things to contend with,
namely Mark Antony and
Cleopatra.
It wasn't until after the
Battle of Actium,
when he got rid of the two of
them, that he had time to build
this Temple to Mars Ultor.
And we see it beginning to go
up in 28 B.C.--
so considerably later than the
original battle--
28 B.C., and it was dedicated
in Rome,
on a very important date,
the date of 2 B.C.
So begun in 28 B.C.
and dedicated in 2 B.C.,
and that's the date that I've
given you on the Monument List,
the dedication of the Temple of
Mars Ultor and the Forum of
Augustus in 2 B.C.
We see its plan here.
We will see momentarily that it
was built in very close
approximation ;
in fact, right next to the
Forum of Julius Caesar.
Why?
Because, of course,
Augustus wanted to associate
himself with his divine adoptive
father Caesar.
So he puts his own forum right
next to Caesar's.
We see the Forum of Augustus
here.
We can see that it follows in
the main, the plan of the Forum
of Julius Caesar.
It is a rectangular space,
open to the sky,
with colonnades on either side,
with a temple in the center,
pushed up against the back
wall, and dominating the space
in front of it.
The only change here is the
addition of these hemicycles,
one on either side,
looking very much like the
hemicycles that we looked at
from the Sanctuary of Fortuna
Primigenia,
at Palestrina:
these embracing arms that
served to accentuate
architecturally and visually the
temple in the center,
and that also served as a
place--there are niches on
either side where they could put
statuary and the like,
seen through the columns,
as you can see here.
The Temple of Mars Ultor
itself, again very similar to
temples,
early Roman temples that we've
been talking about,
using the Etruscan plan:
façade orientation,
single staircase,
deep porch, freestanding
columns in that porch,
freestanding columns on either
side,
but yet, like an Etruscan
temple, a flat back wall.
As you can see here,
some columns inside,
decorating the cella of the
temple, and then a single niche
for the cult statue inside.
And note here also the
base--I'll say something about
the statue that stood on that
base later.
Here's a Google Earth view of
this part of Rome,
showing the connection between.
You can see here the Forum of
Julius Caesar as it looks today.
This is the entrance.
We're moving back toward the
Capitoline Hill.
These are those three columns
that I showed you before,
are still preserved,
as well as the columns of the
colonnade,
on the left side,
that entered into the shops.
Here's the modern Via dei Fori
Imperiali, built by Mussolini.
What Mussolini did was slice
the Roman Forum and Julian Forum
from the so-called Imperial
Fora, to which they were
originally attached;
and any of you who've been in
Rome recently know that this
entire area is being excavated.
The plan is--the street is
still there now,
but the plan is
eventually--we'll see whether
this really happens,
because it would be a traffic
nightmare--
but the plan is to take that
Mussolini street down eventually
and reunite all of these forums
in some great archaeological
park someday.
It would be exciting if that
were to happen.
So the modern street.
But initially the Forum of
Caesar would have stood exactly
next to the Forum of Augustus.
We see that here,
and if you look carefully you
can see the remains of the
Temple of Mars Ultor,
as well as a precinct wall that
is preserved.
It was a 115-foot precinct
wall, protecting the forum from
just the area we were talking
about before--
that question about housing for
the well-to-do and the less
well-to-do in ancient Rome--
protecting the forum from the
so-called Subura,
S-u-b-u-r-a,
which was that area of Rome in
which all of those rickety,
wooden tenement houses were
located and which were
constantly going up in fires,
to protect the temple--because
marble can burn--
to protect the Temple of Mars
Ultor from all of that stuff
that was back there in the
Subura.
Here's another view from Google
Earth,
taken from the other side,
showing the remains of the
Temple of Mars Ultor,
pushed up against the back
wall, and then that precinct
wall,
that is very well-preserved,
snaking its way around,
dividing the forum proper,
the sacred space,
from the residential area
called the Subura that was
behind.
Here's a view of the precinct
wall as it looks from the
outside of the forum today.
There are some additions that
were made in later times,
Medieval-looking windows and
the like, but for the most part
it's preserved as it was.
You can see we're dealing with
ashlar blocks,
made out of peperino
stone, p-e-p-e-r-i-n-o.
We've talked about
peperino before.
It's a form of tufa,
a stone that was used here with
ashlar blocks,
for the encircling precinct
wall.
You can see the coloration of
those peperino blocks,
grayish/brownish color here.
And you can see the difference
between that and the temple,
the remains of the temple,
the columns,
the steps of the temple,
as well as some other
decoration,
and also some of the walls were
made out of Luna or Carrara
marble: Luna or Carrara marble
for this temple.
This is a view of the Temple of
Mars Ultor as it looks today.
It's in ruinous state,
but enough is preserved for us
to get a very good sense of what
it originally looked like.
You can see that the podium is
tall.
You can see that it's made out
of tufa.
You can see that the steps are
sheathed in Carrara marble,
brought from those quarries
that we discussed before.
You can see that the columns
were also made out of solid
Carrara marble.
We see that here.
We see a wall in Carrara
marble, and we see the
distinction between that and the
peperino walls.
You can also see,
in this very good view,
one of the hemicycles on the
left-hand side,
and you can see those niches
that I mentioned before,
that would have held statuary
that you could see through the
columns.
This is a restored view in the
Ward-Perkins textbook,
which shows you what the temple
would have looked like in
antiquity,
when it was in its final form,
and you can see everything
we've described:
the tall podium,
single staircase,
façade orientation.
You can see also that there was
sculpture in the pediment,
and we know something about
that.
You can see the columns on
either side,
and you can see in the second
story--
you can barely make them out
but take my word,
those are, instead of columns
they are figures of women that
we're going to say something
about,
and you can see those again on
both sides.
So this gives you a sense of
what the temple would've looked
like in its heyday.
The favored capital column
type, and capital of the Romans,
the Corinthian,
is what is used here.
You can see a preserved
capital, and how beautifully
rendered they were:
very high quality,
capitals done out of Luna or
Carrara marble.
We can see the characteristic
triple row of acanthus leaves,
the spiral volutes growing out
of those,
the central flower that we see
always in the Corinthian order
for the columns that were used
for the temple and for most of
the side columns on the first
story as well.
But in some cases those columns
were replaced with others that
have instead of the spiral
volutes growing out of the
acanthus leaves,
pegasi, winged horses,
and I show you a detail of one
of those pegasi here.
A capital with an animal,
replacing the spirals,
is called a zoomorphic capital:
zoo, z-o-o;
zoomorphic,
z-o-o-m-o-r-p-h-i-c,
zoomorphic capital.
And it's interesting to note
that we see similar zoomorphic
capitals in Greece a bit earlier
than this structure,
at a gateway that I'm going to
show you at a place called
Eleusis--
we'll return to this when we
discuss Roman Greece later in
this semester--
and these have,
instead of pegasi,
these have bull protomes,
the tops of bulls emanating out
of the acanthus leaves.
But I show it to you to make
one point,
and that is that it seems very
likely that there was some
interesting architectural
exchange--
ideas, architects and so
on--going on between Athens and
Rome in the late Republican
period,
in the time of Julius Caesar
and into the age of Augustus,
and it's an issue that we'll
return to in the future.
We're going to see that
Augustus not only builds his
marble city in order to make it
look more like Greece,
more like Athens,
and to connect his new Golden
Age with the Golden Age of
Periclean Athens,
but we see very specific Greek
models being used.
For example,
one of these is a frieze from
the Forum of Augustus.
The other is a frieze from one
of the three temples on the
Acropolis,
in Athens, of the fifth century
B.C.,
the so-called Erechtheion,
or Erectheum,
in the Latinized version,
and one of these is from one
and one of these is from the
other.
And I just wondered quickly if
any of you want to guess which
is the Roman one and which is
the Greek one that it copies?
You can see this alternation of
the lotus and palmette leaves
here.
Any quick thoughts?
How many of you think this is
the Greek one?
This is the Roman one;
this is the Roman one at the
top, this is the Greek one down
here.
The Greek one down here,
more deeply undercut,
which is I think what throws
people.
The Roman one,
from the Forum of Augustus up
above.
But the important point for us
again, that they are looking
back at Greek buildings of the
fifth century,
and they are copying what they
see.
We see here a model of the
Forum of Augustus,
with the Temple of Mars Ultor
inside that forum,
with the embracing exedrae or
hemicycles on either side.
You can see that the exterior
of the structure was quite
plain,
just in the way that a Domus
Italica outside was plain,
and it was only when you got
inside that you got a real sense
of the glory of the
architecture.
So I think you can see well
here.
And most interesting for us,
I mentioned that these columns
on the temple were Corinthian;
the columns on the first story
over here were Corinthian.
But in the second story,
on the left and right sides of
the forum,
the columns are replaced by
figures of women,
by figures of maidens,
and I show you two of them have
survived--
two of them are well-preserved.
I show them to you here.
These figures of maidens that
replace the columns,
that support the capitals,
on top of their heads,
and they flank this shield in
the center with the depiction of
a male head.
This is the god Jupiter,
a certain guise of the god
Jupiter,
Jupiter Ammon,
as you can see him here,
and we have information that
tells us that Alexander the
Great used to place shields in
the Parthenon in Athens,
and elsewhere,
after great military victories,
and it is possible that that
sort of thing is being referred
to here,
because we know Augustus,
like Pompey before him,
had a thing for Alexander and
liked to associate himself with
Alexander.
But most important for us is
the fact that these maidens have
clear precedents in the Greek
world.
The famous Porch of the Maidens
on the Athenian Acropolis,
fifth century B.C.,
the Erechtheion again--
E-r-e-c-h-t-h-e-i-o-n,
in the Greek version--
the Erectheion of Athens,
fifth century B.C.
Same set of maidens.
We know that these had fallen
into disrepair in the age of
Augustus.
Augustus visited Athens three
times.
He did not like seeing these in
disrepair,
and in fact he had his own
architects replace one of them
with a Roman copy,
and while they were doing that,
they made plaster casts of
these maidens,
they brought those plaster
casts back to Rome,
and then in reduced scale they
duplicated them for the Forum of
Augustus in Rome.
So appropriations from Greece;
appropriations in part because
Augustus liked them,
but also I don't think there's
any question that he was trying
to draw a relationship between
himself,
his new Golden Age,
and the Golden Age of Periclean
Athens.
We also have evidence for what
the pediment,
the sculpture in the pediment
looked like, and I want to turn
to that now.
This is a relief that dates to
a slightly later period that
purports to represent the
pediment of the Temple of Mars
Ultor.
And I show it to you here,
and we can tell from this
exactly what the sculptural
display was all about in the
pediment of this temple.
We see here in the center,
not surprisingly,
Mars Ultor himself;
Mars Ultor depicted with a bare
chest.
Next to him,
to his right,
to our left,
we see a figure of a woman.
This is Venus,
and Venus, as you can see,
has something on her left
shoulder.
It is a Cupid.
So Venus with Cupid,
Venus the consort of Mars.
And then over here a
personification that we believe
depicts Fortuna:
Fortuna, the goddess of
Fortune, who brought fortune to
Augustus in his battle.
And then over here,
a seated figure of Roma,
with her arms and armor.
Keep this figure in your mind,
because I'm going to show you
another seated Roma very soon.
And then over here,
a reclining figure of the Tiber
River, the river on which Rome
was built.
Over here, a seated figure we
believe is Romulus,
the founder of Rome,
on the Palatine Hill.
And over here a reclining
personification of the Palatine.
So, most important,
that the building honored,
of course, Mars Ultor,
and that Mars Ultor was
depicted in the pediment.
There was also a cult statue
inside the Temple of Mars,
and we believe we know what
that looked like as well,
because we believe we have a
copy of it in a relief from
Algiers that is still preserved,
that depicts Mars,
in the center,
this Mars Ultor again,
this time the warlike Mars
Ultor, because you can see he's
wearing his breastplate and his
helmet.
His consort,
Venus, is once again by his
side.
Venus is leaning on a pedestal.
She's very seductive.
Her drapery is falling off her
shoulder, as you can see,
as she looks toward Mars.
And then Cupid down here,
offering her a sword in a
sheath, probably Mars' own
sword.
And then over here a figure
that's very controversial,
a youthful looking figure with
a bare chest,
and you can see a full cap of
hair,
and we think that he is
actually the divinized Julius
Caesar,
very botoxed compared to
what--he's rejuvenated compared
to what he looked like in that
green diabase portrait that I
showed you before:
a very youthful,
divine Caesar,
which shows you what happens to
people in Roman times when they
were divinized.
They were able to shed a fair
number of years and were
depicted in much younger
versions in their divinized
state.
So this probably a reflection.
As you can see,
the figures stand on bases,
and figures that stand on bases
in Roman relief sculpture are
usually meant to be statues,
and we believe that this is
again a rendition of what that
triple set of statues would have
looked like inside the temple.
To return to the plan quickly,
just to make the point that the
sculptural program--
we're concerned here primarily
with architecture--
but the sculptural program was
very complicated,
but very interesting,
and the figures were very
carefully aligned with one
another to get the message
across.
So as you looked at the temple,
you would have seen Mars Ultor
in the center of the pediment.
If you were allowed to walk
into the temple,
which usually only the priests
could do,
you would see the cult statue
with Mars Ultor in the center
there.
There was an equestrian statue
that was put up,
of Augustus in 2 B.C.,
when he was given the title
Pater Patriae,
the father of his country.
And then all along the
colonnades there would've been
statuary,
including an image of Aeneas on
this side,
Romulus on this side,
and the so-called summi
viri,
the great men of Rome,
both Augustus' colleagues and
also his rivals,
in their portraits on either
side: a kind of giant picture
gallery,
a giant portrait gallery of
Rome, of the great men of Rome,
of the greatest men of Rome,
namely Augustus himself,
and of his ancestry,
both divine and mythological,
via Aeneas and also Venus.
The second marble building that
I want to show you today is the
famous Altar of Augustan Peace,
the Ara Pacis Augustae,
which is one of,
if not my most favorite
building and monument in Rome,
and one that I've had a
personal obsession with my
entire scholarly life.
I've written a lot on this
monument and have a lot of
thoughts, which have changed
significantly over the years,
about this very important
structure.
We know about it--Augustus
tells us about the Altar of
Augustan Peace himself in his
Res Gestae.
He tells us on his return--and
I'm quoting Augustus here,
from the RG--on his
return to Rome from Spain and
Gaul;
he had gone to Spain and Gaul,
which were the western part of
the Empire, in order to make
some diplomatic treaties.
"On my return to Rome from
Spain and Gaul,
after successfully restoring
law and order to the provinces,
the Senate decided"
(and this happened in 13 B.C.)
"to consecrate the Ara
Pacis Augustae,
on the Campus Martius"
(the so-called Field of Mars,
an area of Rome) "in honor
of my return,
at which officials,
priests and Vestal Virgins
should offer an annual
sacrifice."
We believe that the monument
being referred to here is the
one that you see now before you,
The Ara Pacis Augustae,
made entirely of Luna or
Carrara marble,
solid Luna or Carrara marble,
and even more of a marble
building,
in a sense, than the temple and
forum that we've looked at thus
far.
It is a marble building that we
believe that we know.
We know its dates quite
specifically.
We know that it was consecrated
on the 4^(th) of July--an easy
date to remember,
for all of us--the 4^(th) of
July in 13 B.C.
was when it was consecrated,
and it was completed and
dedicated on the 30^(th) of
January in 9 B.C.;
the 30^(th) of January just
happened to be the birthday of
Augustus' wife,
Livia.
No coincidence there.
She was obviously lobbying for
that.
So on her birthday,
30^(th) of January in 9 B.C.,
this structure is dedicated.
We know that it--there's a lot
of controversy as to exactly
what event is referred to on
this monument,
because we'll see that there is
a procession that refers to some
historical event.
We will also see that the
monument is covered with all
kinds of sculptural decoration,
including flowering acanthus
plants,
including mythological and
legendary scenes,
including historical scenes.
And trying to decipher the web
of all these and their
relationship to one another is
fairly complex.
What's important to us as we
look at this is--
and I want to show you here,
from Ward-Perkins,
a plan and an axonometric view,
which will give us a very good
sense of what this altar was all
about.
We can see that the altar
proper was located in the center
of the structure.
It's a kind of u-shaped altar,
which goes back to Greek
precedents.
The most famous u-shaped altar
of the Hellenistic period,
some of you may know it,
the Altar of Zeus at Pergamon,
the great Altar of Zeus at
Pergamon,
which you see in the uppermost
part,
now in Berlin.
But these u-shaped altars were
used in Greece,
and you can see that same
u-shaped form here,
used for the altar.
The altar proper,
where the sacrifice was
actually made,
is located inside this
precinct, which is open to the
sky,
and most importantly has double
doors: a doorway on the eastern
side of the monument and a
doorway on the western side of
the monument.
Even though there are two
doors, you note that there is
only a single staircase on the
western side.
So the Romans,
despite the fact that they've
given it a dual focus by putting
two doors, they still give it a
single focus by a single
staircase.
So facadism of Roman
architecture reigned supreme,
as you can see here.
The fact that there were double
doorways -- very significant,
and we've tried to sort out why
that might be.
There are two possible
precedents or two possible
references that are being made
here.
One, to a Greek altar,
a Greek fifth-century B.C.
altar, which shouldn't surprise
us since we've seen that
Augustus is looking back at the
fifth century B.C.
in Greece and mining it for
architectural ideas and
associations.
We see here what is a restored
view of the Altar of the Twelve
Gods,
or the Altar of Pity,
that was located in the Greek
marketplace,
in Athens, the Athenian Agora,
the marketplace in Athens,
fifth century B.C.
You can see that it consisted
of an altar in the center,
with a precinct wall,
with double doorways,
one on either side here,
and with relief sculpture.
So it looks like that might
well be an important model,
again not surprisingly since it
dates to the fifth century.
But also important,
and I show you an image of it
on a Roman coin here,
is the so-called Shrine of
Janus--the two-headed god,
J-a-n-u-s, the Shrine of Janus,
which we know is located in the
Roman Forum.
And tradition had it that when
the doors--because it had double
doors;
well it had two sides because
he was a two-headed god.
So two sides,
both with doors,
both with double doors,
and that when those double
doors were closed,
it signaled that peace reigned
throughout the Empire.
And we know in the Res
Gestae, Augustus tells us
that he closed the doors of the
Shrine of Janus,
he brags, three times during
his reign.
So it is very likely that the
double doors on the Shrine of
Janus are referred to,
not surprisingly,
in an altar that was put up to
peace,
to the peace that Augustus
brought to Rome through his
various military victories and
also through his diplomatic
conquests,
his diplomatic treaties like
the one that he signed in Spain
and Gaul.
I want to take you quickly
through the monument--
and keep in mind always that
it's made out of Luna or Carrara
marble--
to show you some of the--this
is not a course in sculpture,
so I'm not going to go into the
sculpture in any detail,
but I want you to be aware of
it because some of the motifs
are important in our
understanding also of
architecture.
We see here two views of the
altar.
You see these winged lion
griffins that are very popular
motifs in the Augustan period,
as well as the spiraling
acanthus plant that was also
popular in Augustan times.
A figural frieze that
represents the Vestal Virgins
that were referred to as those
to which offerings are--
the sacrifice is taking place
in part in honor of them.
But we see here a sacrifice
itself where the animal victims
are being brought in for
slaughter.
We also see if we look
at--we're now inside the
monument, we've looked at the
altar proper.
If we look at the precinct
wall, the inside of the precinct
wall,
we see that is very
well-preserved,
and we see it is zoned,
essentially two zones,
with slats, all done in Carrara
marble,
slats down below that look like
either a wooden wall or perhaps
a fence of some sort.
Then above, also depicted in
Carrara marble,
these great garlanded swags
that you see hanging from
pilasters,
but also from the skulls of
bulls--I'll show you a detail in
a moment where you'll see those
skulls better--
the skulls of the bulls that
have been sacrificed on this
altar.
And then above the swags you
can see these libation dishes.
And what has been
speculated--and I think it's
ingenious on the part of the
scholars who first came up with
this--
that what they think is being
represented here is actually a
copy or a rendition of the
wooden,
the temporary wooden altar that
would've stood on this site.
Because remember they're
consecrating it already in 13
B.C.,
but the structure itself isn't
built until 9,
and they have to keep offering
this annual sacrifice.
So they have to offer it
somewhere.
So the suggestion is they made
a makeshift wooden altar,
that looked like this,
with actual wooden slats,
wooden poles,
real garlands and so on,
and that what they've done on
the altar is to create a
rendition of that on the
interior precinct wall of the
Ara Pacis.
A detail of these garlands.
Here you can see the bull
skulls or bucrania
extremely well,
and I thought you'd be
interested to see,
and perhaps not surprised,
that we can see very close
renditions of this also in
painting of the time.
This painting on the left comes
from the House of Livia in Rome.
We didn't look at it;
we looked at the Villa of Livia
at Primaporta,
and we looked at Augustus'
house, but when we did that I
told you Livia had her own house
across the street from
Augustus',
and this painting is from that.
It's clearly a Second Style
wall, residual First Style:
done in paint;
projecting columns;
garlands hanging from those
columns, garlands interlaced
with ribbons,
just as you see here.
And when this was painted,
which it was in antiquity,
it would've looked very similar
to what you see on the other
side of the screen.
So interesting
inter-relationships between
decoration in sculpture and
architecture,
and decoration in paint.
The axonometric view again
shows you--
here's that inner precinct that
we've just described--
that the outside had a series
of panels,
square panels,
four of them on the short sides
and then--
or on the front sides,
where the doors are,
flanking the doors -- and then
on the other sides,
the north and south, a frieze.
And I show you a detail of that
frieze;
a frieze, the subject matter of
which is somewhat controversial.
I'm not going to go into that
here today.
Suffice it to say though that
Augustus,
senators, magistrates,
members of the priesthood,
members of the imperial family,
all take part in these
processions that are located on
the north and south.
Those processions rest on these
acanthus plants down below,
which when you think of it has
absolutely nothing to do with
reality,
because how could a procession
of human figures be supported by
acanthus plants below?
Impossible, and yet it is--some
of that fantasy thinking that we
saw in Third Style Roman
painting,
and I show you--I remind you of
a detail of Garden Room Q over
here,
where we saw some of that
fanciful Third Style painting,
seems to come into play here.
In fact, the delicate acanthus
leaves, absolutely beautifully
rendered in the Ara Pacis.
You see the same sort of thing
in the black background of the
Garden Room Q.
So again, interesting
correspondences between painting
and architectural decoration.
The frieze on the south side
has a portrait of Augustus
himself.
You can see him here veiled,
taking part in this procession,
as well as members of the
imperial family,
including children.
Here's a little boy in a toga,
and here's a little boy who's
very controversial in some kind
of a foreign costume.
And I mentioned that I've
written a lot on this,
and in my most recent article
on this subject I talked in
particular about these children
in foreign dress as possibly
children who were what we call
"pledges of empire,"
or hostage guests,
that belonged--that were
children of very important
rulers of other parts of the
world who were brought to Rome
to live with the emperor in his
house,
in the palace,
to be trained,
with the objective of
eventually sending them back to
their native lands to serve as
rulers.
It was Augustus' way of
creating a kind of hegemonic
empire that he controlled,
by getting all of these people
on his side and then placing
those friends of Rome into
important positions around the
world,
and I think that's referred to
in these scenes.
Again, I'm not going go in any
detail into the mythological
scenes,
but they are scenes like Roma,
seated on a pile of arms and
armor,
just as we saw her in the
pediment of the Temple of Mars
Ultor.
And here a scene that seems to
have shown Mars overseeing
Romulus and Remus being suckled
by the she-wolf.
So references to Rome's
historic and also legendary and
mythological past clearly in
this monument.
Perhaps most interesting to all
of us from the point of view of
architecture is the original
location of this monument in
relationship to Augustus' tomb,
and also what has been
happening there in recent years,
under the direction of the
famous American architect
Richard Meier.
I show you a view from Google
Earth,
an aerial view,
showing the Mausoleum of
Augustus,
this large round tomb that we
will look at on Thursday,
showing a piazza around it,
and showing,
from the air,
the Richard Meier Museum that
has been built to enclose the
Ara Pacis.
This was not--right near the
Tiber River--this was not the
original location of the Ara
Pacis, which was up over here.
It ended up beneath a palace in
the Renaissance period,
and at that time some pieces of
it were taken apart and made
their way to museums in Rome,
but also to museums as far away
as Paris.
And it is actually to Mussolini
that we can be grateful for
bringing all of those pieces
back together and reconstructing
the Ara Pacis--
couldn't reconstruct it,
because that palace is still
there now--
but reconstructing it right on
the Tiber River,
next to the Mausoleum of
Augustus, and then having this
whole piazza redesigned as the
piazza honoring Augustus:
the Piazza Augusto Imperatore
honoring Augustus,
but also honoring Mussolini,
because there's a major
inscription to Mussolini,
as well as buildings very much
in the so-called Fascist style.
We see the Meier building again
here.
And I show you the
travertine--because Meier was
careful to use at least some
travertine in this
structure--the travertine base;
although this was not his,
this actually belongs to an
original precinct that was
located before,
that was done by Mussolini's
architect,
with the entire text of the
Res Gestae.
Fortunately Meier kept that and
kept that wall as part of his
own building.
Here you see one of the Fascist
structures in the area,
built by Mussolini,
and then the famous Alfredo
Ristorante.
I'm not actually recommending
it, but it's well known;
there are better restaurants to
eat in Rome,
but because it has a certain
historical caché,
at any rate I just mention to
you that it's there.
This is the interesting
inscription that makes reference
to Mussolini.
And note the flying victory
figure,
which we'll see decorates often
Roman arches,
carrying this bundle of twigs
and rods that the Romans,
the Roman bodyguards of the
emperor used to carry,
these so-called fasces.
If you ever wondered where the
word Fascism comes from,
it comes from the Roman
fasces.
Mussolini's name,
you can see part of it here,
M-U-S-S-O-L;
part of it scratched out after
his death and discredit in the
'30s.
And then ultimately,
what's been interesting to me
is I've watched this inscription
and photographed it year after
year, whenever I'm there.
I've noticed recently that he's
having--
there's something of a revival
-- and he is,
Mussolini is having something
of a revival in Italy,
and there's a good deal of
interest in him,
and they have filled his name
-- when they redid the museum
they also re-filled in his name,
as you can see here.
I just wanted to make a point
about the siting of the Ara
Pacis and its relationship to
the Mausoleum of Augustus.
Remember, it's no longer--its
original location--now it's over
here, right next to the
Mausoleum on the Tiber.
That was not its original
location.
It was located over here,
along the ancient Via Flaminia,
the street that Augustus took
when he returned from Spain and
Gaul.
It was put up right here,
and it had in front of it an
obelisk that was brought from
Egypt,
and that obelisk was part of a
sundial that was orchestrated
carefully enough so that the
shadow from the sundial would
fall exactly on the center of
the Ara Pacis,
on Augustus' birthday.
That's how carefully
orchestrated it was,
and the fact that there is an
Egyptian obelisk,
and there's mention in the
inscription on that obelisk of
the victory over Cleopatra and
Antony,
at the Battle of Actium,
and that the Ara Pacis
commemorates his diplomatic
treaties in the western part of
the Empire,
in France and Spain,
seems to me to be a reference
to the fact that Augustus was
victorious in all parts of the
Roman Empire:
the western as well as the
eastern part of the Empire,
referenced here.
And then close proximity to the
Mausoleum of Augustus.
Because we've already talked
about the fact that in the minds
of the Romans,
victory in battle and victory
over death were essentially
synonymous;
both of them referred to here.
I'm not implying that this was
planned as a complex.
The Mausoleum,
as we'll see on Thursday,
dates to 28 to 23.
It was built much earlier than
the Altar of 13 to 9.
But I think when they decided
to add the Ara Pacis to this
complex,
there was a great deal of
thought that was given to siting
it in relationship to the tomb,
and to thinking about the whole
as a complex,
at least at that particular
juncture.
And I show you two more
restored views,
where you can see the obelisk
and the way in which it cast--
it served as a sundial--cast a
shadow toward the Ara Pacis.
And then, even though this is a
little bit out of focus,
the relationship of the very
large tomb to the obelisk and
ultimately to the Ara Pacis.
So an area that was not planned
as a complex but grew into one.
An image of Mussolini,
a wonderful photograph of
Mussolini,
visiting the Ara Pacis after it
was restored and dedicated and
placed in a complex designed by
his architect.
And then an image down here of
Richard Meier,
celebrating the cleaning and
placement of the Ara Pacis
inside the new museum designed
by him.
And in just a few minutes I'd
like to run through a series of
slides.
Because I think a particularly
interesting issue for all of us,
and one that I hope that we
will debate in the online forum,
is the fact that the building
by Richard Meier,
this museum,
which has been praised and
maligned both,
this museum is the first modern
building that has been put up in
the central core of Rome,
since the time of Mussolini,
since Mussolini redesigned the
Piazza Augusto Imperatore and
added some other buildings to
the landscape of Rome.
There are other--there are
buildings by major architects,
including Meier himself.
Meier built a Jubilee Church a
few years--a number of years
ago, and Renzo Piano,
and other architects have been
working in Rome.
But they are not--their
buildings are located on the
outskirts, the sort of suburbs
of the city, and not in the city
itself.
This is the only new building
that has been added to the city.
And you can see,
from this particular view,
why some people think of it as
a kind of white elephant that
really doesn't fit the tenor of
the city.
And, in fact,
when it first opened in 2006--
and I was there not long after,
and taking some photographs of
some pictures of the building
that were outside that had
been--
that graffiti had been added
to, and they call it the Meier
"criminale."
And over here,
this is my favorite,
it says: "meglio gli
architetti di secoli fa,"
meaning those architects of the
past were a lot better than
Meier,
is the message here.
So there are many people who do
not like this building,
and I think a case can be made
with regard to the outside.
There is a nod to ancient Rome
with the travertine wall that is
outside and continues inside.
But it's typical Meier white
glass,
and a lot of people--I don't
mind that sort of thing,
but a lot of people feel that
it doesn't really suit the
environment with the two Baroque
churches right across the way,
and so on and so forth.
So I think a case can be made
for the exterior.
But when you enter into the
museum,
and pay your fee,
and then go into the door,
and into the Ara Pacis itself,
I have to say--
and past the plaster casts of
Augustus and his family,
that you can see lined up
against the travertine wall--
when you confront the building
itself,
in its new interior,
I have to say I'm very
impressed and very moved by this
interior.
You've got the sort of egg
crate ceiling and these
wonderful louvered windows that
allow you to see not only
Mussolini's Fascist buildings
next door,
but also the Mausoleum of
Augustus,
that it really--and the light
is superb,
and it really does give you a
chance to see this altar in a
way that it hasn't been seen
before.
And especially at night,
I enjoy seeing it at night,
because as you go by it they
have it lighted up.
As you drive by--one of the
greatest things to do in Rome,
by the way, is late at night,
when all the traffic has died
down,
either by car or Vespa or
whatever,
just get around the city,
go from one part of the city to
another,
which you can zip around late
at night.
And driving along Lungotevere,
the street along the Tiber
River,
and seeing the altar,
the Ara Pacis Augustae lighted
up inside the new Meier Museum,
like a jewel in a jewel box,
I can't help but think Augustus
is smiling somewhere to think
that everything he did to try to
preserve his memory for
posterity has been done,
and has been helped to a great
extent by the great American
architect,
Richard Meier.
Thank you.